nous sommes avec philippe bélair
secrétaire général de la fédération
santé de la cgt guadeloupe philippe
meslay remercie d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors on disait 20
personnes décédées ducobu 19 la semaine
dernière 35 personnes actuellement en
réanimation
la situation est elle très inquiétante
selon vous les plus inquiétantes dans la
mesure où je vous rappelle que depuis
l'an dernier nous avions fait un
mouvement social ou déjà nous dénoncions
le manque de moyens puisque nous nous
rapprochons les deux événements nous
savions que nous savons toujours
d'ailleurs comme nous sommes dans un
pays x à fort risque
nous ne savions même pas que le cette
affaire de kovy d'arrivée mais déjà en
tant que pays à hauts risques avec les
tremblements de terre avec la d'autres
épidémies comme koné santis qui
d'ailleurs nous sommes en période de
rigueur de l'adec nous avons le récit
tonique et le risque volcanique et nous
avions dénoncé déjà le manque de
matériel
aujourd'hui nous faisons face à en
pratiquer véritablement pratique à ce
que nous craignons l'an dernier et voilà
la situation elle sans pino non
seulement parce qu'effectivement il y a
des cas de couples vide mais il ya aussi
un véritable problème de moyens de
personnel justement quels sont les
moyens matériels et humains qu'il vous
manque aujourd'hui
alors c'est pas particulièrement des
soignants particulièrement du matériel
de soin particulier au moment qu'on
arrête les versions du budgétaire parce
qu'aujourd'hui on nous parle de
mutualisation de moyens mais en fait
c'est de la concentration de moyens et
c'est là le drame la guadeloupe n'est
pas seule dans le cas où tous les
hôpitaux de france et de navarre sont
dans ce cas là même nous
particulièrement et je pense aussi que
nous la martinique c'est aussi le cas ce
sont des zones à haut risque où il faut
véritablement que les autorités
sanitaires et un autre déroulement de
pensée par rapport à
nos problématiques insulaires alors
quelles sont les populations les plus
touchées aujourd'hui
alors effectivement nous avons un gros
problème de kokomo visite puisque nous
sommes aussi dans une population déjà
qui vieillit énormément en plus de ça et
à d'autres pathologies du genre diabète
pathologie des gens quand ce cancer
successifs d'ailleurs notamment à tous
les empoisonnements thériault que nous
avons subies avec la chlordécone dans
d'autres pathologies 4 et nous avons une
maladie particulière s'il avait pas de
sitôt ce qui a fait osciller des voies
respiratoires
en cas de crise donc nous avons une
population déjà fragilisée et en plus
avec les risques nous avons tous
véritablement tout nous l'avions prévu
encore une fois les autorités sanitaires
et politiques n'ont pas voulu écouter
parce qu'ils sont dans une logique
libérale une logique de réduction
budgétaire
et voilà le travail alors dû du coup
pour vous comment est-ce qu'il faut
appréhender la situation aujourd'hui on
sait que treize militaires ont été
envoyés pour prêter main forte
déjà quel est leur rôle sur place et
qu'est ce qui vous manque
comment articuler finalement cette lutte
contre l'épidémie sur l'île selon vous
écoutez je vais vous le dire tout le
problème est dans le financement le mont
financement bien fléché avec le matériel
les moyens humains des moyens financiers
les moyens matériels qu'il faut c'est ça
le problème c'est que on a concentré
tous les moyens nous avons douze
hôpitaux tous les moyens quasiment sur
le seul chu de lille
certes mais le problème c'est que le chu
et est en grande difficulté et voire
même en difficulté financière d'ailleurs
mais aussi en difficultés fonctionnelles
le chu ne peux pas répondre à ça le chu
ne peux pas répondre ils ont bien ils
ont beau faire un plan b un plan blanc
pardon ce plan blanc ne répond même
difficilement
à la crise sanitaire tout simplement
parce que les choses ont été mal pensée
très très mal pensée et la réaction par
rapport à ses débuts dès le départ n'a
pas été la bonne en tout cas votre sens
les restos restent ouverts les salles de
sport également est ce que il faudrait
prendre des mesures plus drastiques
selon vous justement pour faire face à
cette épidémie
ou alors il y avait effectivement une
situation économique qui est elle aussi
est en crise sur place oui il ya une
situation économique déjà avant la crise
salutaire il y avait déjà une cuisse à
l'économique patenté récurent attendant
ce pays mais la crise sanitaire va
accélérer les choses il est clair et net
que l'économie va va en pâtir d'ici deux
ou trois mois
ceci dit les restaurateurs pour répondre
précisément à votre question on était au
tribunal administratif
le restaurateur et les salles de sport
c'est la raison pour laquelle ils ont la
possibilité aujourd'hui parce que la
tribune jean igen cause devant le
tribunal administratif qui a demandé au
préfet de revoir de revoir son arrêté
préfectoral puisqu'au départ il était
convenu depuis dimanche soir que tout le
monde ferme basque lido à 100%
aujourd'hui les choses seront mitigés ce
qui leur permet de d'avoir une réaction
sur le thème une archi économique autre
que ce qui était prévu pour la
préfecture le président emmanuel macron
veut plus de restrictions il a annoncé
ce soir là où le virus circule trop vite
il faut plus de restrictions aujourd'hui
en boyau pour vous également écouter le
virus est là il faut qu'on sache que le
vieux sellal et quand je dis ça je ne
dis pas qu'il ne faille pas prendre ses
précautions
il faut prendre ses précautions mais le
virus est là et il le dit cela pour un
moment il va falloir faire avec
je l ai déjà dit martelé sur d'autres
médias il va falloir qu'on appelle à
faire avec
autrement vivre autrement vivre
peut-être avec beaucoup plus de
précautions mais nous avons l'impression
que le gouvernement en fait les
autorités aussi des politiques
sanitaires essaie de se rattraper par
rapport
coupé du début de la crise sanitaire
mais non l'aurez deviné oui c'est là et
je crois qu la population l'a
parfaitement compris la population prend
les précautions nécessaires bien sûr il
ya quelques individus qui prennent
comment dirais-je des risques j'ai
quelques individualités ne sont pas la
généralité la grande majorité de la
population prend ses précautions
je peux vous l'assurer merci beaucoup
philippe bélair d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général de la fédération
santé de la cgt boîte